one may a group of penguins were
enjoying themselves in the icy tundra
the Penguins like to swim and play and
generally do whatever is his most famous
do there was one particular penguin
however who was different than the Reds
and he also was the littlest family
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the littlest penguin now
this is a game about a penguin and I'm
sure it's going to be only lovely and
amazing and everything is gonna turn out
great up to jump oh oh look at the tiny
little jump oh oh look at that what a
little penguin
oh boo ski oh that don't work apparently
hey wait wait a minute I'm not not
exactly a hundred percent sure how to
control the littlest bang Grenier let me
dive wow that is scary here it is
there we go penguin like the other
penguins when fighting up albeit in
small doses of course it was much more
interested in going on adventures yeah
just a good possibly best adventure yet
I would agree
thank you so much for allowing me to go
on this epic incredible adventure yeah
nothing dark a sinister one lurking
around the corner see it whoa hello what
the hell is that
there's an awkward scene transition that
okay oh hi ah just then he discovered a
very oh very sick
penguin lying next to a large stone
won't you please help me cried out me Oh
I'm very safe I'm very old please won't
you help fulfill no Penguins request the
littlest penguin agreed and was
horrified by what the old penguin said
next bash my head in with this stone and
my pain littlest penguin and let this
penguin did as he was told
ah don't have any say in this matter
don't I know I get a little bit of you
know input on the adventure that's about
to unfold before me oh god this feels
like heaven noble tried out of the
littlest thing set out fresh and
threaded given new direction
it came just one pinguin that would be
if I count 10 penguins and off he went
to test history
again that way oh thank you for guiding
me I don't have any choice in the matter
what happens if I go the other way well
I just kill those banquets I'm just
gonna go all the way you tell me to go
oh oh man Oh came upon a small group of
his peers this will do he thought to
himself picking up a club that had been
lying in the snow ha ha ha that's a good
narration Oh God spooked the others but
to his surprise that is miss penguin
before the bubble they ran the greater
his satisfaction when he finally beat
them down and beat them down he did
until the last of them were reduced to
little more oh my god this is amazing
and horrible is it so sudden is it
sudden look like my god just a club
lying in the snow randomly and
sporadically and then off to murder we
go Oh success I don't know if I'd call
this a success but it's advanced and
move for the crowd in order to reach the
other side but if this penguin felt the
eyes upon him the other penguins began
to grow weary of him shifting their gaze
as he walked by I do not like the way
they stare at me thought the littlest
penguin I do not like it one bit
perhaps after I kill them all I shall
make a fine necklace of their eyes
this thought occupied the little penguin
as the other mobile nerves
and perhaps a crown meat from their
beaks so all can see and marvel at how
beautiful I am
okay you think that they keep doing more
than just giving me a shifty look Oh
oh jeez something uh something slightly
wrong about this little penguin here
nothing uh something about being tiny
and full of anger something I can relate
to very much just not to this level oh
boy oh good I'm on a platform now is
this the stage I so set for my murderous
campaign oh hi what the hell is Oh
oh cool an Arctic research center
Oh Oh this was more like it
thoughtful if this penguin Wow good now
return the other thing do it on his plan
look at that [ __ ] yeah oh oh look out
shaky he is a get that penguin murder in
jail antiva this is just a little bit
zpool oh boy
hi friends hello how are you doing
oh shut them again they would cry out
it's easy to clean crime Derek
oh how he wish this moment could last
the route Charlotte host inside of him
he would no sooner explain a magic
behind easily food any more than he
could bring himself to stop we all turn
to every last pinguin that be split
apart
Mike this narrator is good by the way
oh man I really like this story
definitely deserved a date of an
Attenborough style narration my goodness
well I hope that's the end because holy
[ __ ] haha oh that's the end okay David
Mills suits in news narration by
Balthazar double twitching and he no
longer felt the eyes upon him did this
penguin stopped breathing heavily he
surveyed the destruction he had wrought
we are all so beautiful now too
beautiful
in fact the ecstasy felt by limitless
slowly faded and an undeniable sensin
emptiness began to take its place it's
not oh no oh no they're also notable now
why can't I be beautiful like there I
must I be the only one it isn't fair it
just isn't fair that Italy's penguin
looked at the chain saw ripped off the
teeth of the blade almost glistening in
the moonlight suddenly the littlest
penguin knew how to feel beautiful like
the rest he knew then what it was he
must do Oh God
Oh God Oh the game won Oh God no stop
joy stop it I can't do it again oh man
oh wow oh wow what a game what a games
oh what a game holy crap penguin oh I
think it goes without saying don't go on
a chainsaw murder suicide spree don't do
that holy [ __ ] oh man so like 10% of me
actually enjoyed that experience and
then like the other 90% of me wishes
that I could just wash my brain so I
never had to experience any of the
[ __ ] that I just saw but either way
that was the littlest penguin though
thank you everybody so much for watching
for what it was and I hope you gonna
laugh maybe I don't know so thank you
again let me know what you thought the
deeper meaning of this game was in the
comments down below
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye I was always hoping that
I'd have this intimate control over my
buttocks I'm glad that this day has
finally come today all my chance no
chance no matter virgin cow cow cow